Hey everybody, I have had a lot of
requests recently to go over how we
structure a basic go to market
infrastructure setup
and
I think for a while our main value
proposition was to do just do it
ourselves right and we've seen that
especially for
horizontal software or software
platforms that almost anyone can use or
a large segment of the market can
uh just going and sending emails for
clients alongside 10 or 20 BDRs does not
work very well. They're account
executives own a huge portion of the
market. There's a lot of stepping on
feet. And so lately, we've been having a
lot of success with helping companies
set up their go to market
infrastructure, their outbound
infrastructure, their revenue
infrastructure. And I generally partner
with people who are much more skilled on
the HubSpot side of things. But I think
I can at least explain the basics of how
it works. I can do the basic HubSpot
enrichment. But this is the full go to
market architecture. What do I include
in that? That is sending infrastructure.
That's clay tables. That's stuff going
in and out of HubSpot. Those
automations. There's lead routing
automations.
And then finally, there's copywriting
and and context generation. Um, I guess
I would put copywriting into like a
general prospect intelligence system
because we use the prospect intelligence
system to generate information that lets
us do the copywriting.
And I would also put like AI replies
into the lead routing section. So, we'll
get there. I don't want to explain too
much before, but I do want to explain
how we do fit these GTM infrastructure
setups in just three months. Um,
something interesting to note is that
the bottlenecks are almost never on our
side. There are so many things to
consider and that's why it's so
important to have a good discovery and
audit phase within the first month. Now,
a lot of companies are looking to get
started really fast and they skip that
and it actually ends up making things
take longer. So, what are some common
instances that we've seen or problems
that we've seen uh working with our
partners? Like we've had random ones
where like gong calls have been
disconnected for like three years. So,
we have to go in and manually associate
them and that ends up making the close
loss campaigns take longer. And
basically what I'm take say is like
there are a set of fundamental go to
market motions that most companies want
to do and those generally if I if it was
just dependent on me would take like a
month right but the purpose of a goto
market infrastructure
is to involve the partner company who
you're setting this up for and teach
them how to use it and so generally that
takes about 3 months. So I've scoped it
out here kind of you know accurately as
like first month is discovery and audit
phase. Um
second month or I should say month one
as I'm calling it here is infrastructure
setup and where like a majority of the
intense work happens and then month two
we're setting things up for the future
doing education and things like that. So
by all means I'm not the expert of all
experts. Other people might structure
their infrastructure setups for
companies in different ways or they
might be focused more on the the revenue
architecture than the um go to market
architecture. At the end of the day it
all sort of feeds into each other. So
let's just talk about the steps here. So
discovery phase super important
expectation setting what does a
successful engagement looks like? And
I've had to do a lot of work here
because generally I I understood that
companies would understand
that go to market motions especially
setting things up well for the future
and and fixing years of mistakes and
inefficiencies would take more than like
18 or or 30 days um before we started
seeing like considerable pipeline
generation. But this is super important.
Set the expectation that like, hey, the
first 30 days, we're not expecting to do
anything other than get to know you and
your systems. Month two is where the
sending and the pipeline generation will
ideally happen, but we've seen it take
as long as 6 months. Like a good story
from one of my engineers who used to be
an SDR at a large multinational company
was put in charge of finding outbound
motions that worked.
Month one, nothing. Month two, nothing.
Month three, nothing. On and on and on.
Month nine, they cracked it and started
making the company millions of dollars.
So, I'm not saying that outbound motions
have to take that long. But you probably
didn't crack ads on your first campaign.
You probably didn't develop your other
channels in one month or two months. I'm
not saying the pipeline generation can't
happen in the first month or the second
month, but I like to temper expectations
here. So we evaluate the team structure.
Who are we going to be working with? Who
is like we're going to leave at some
point like Stellar Growth or whatever
company that is setting up the
infrastructure. We'll leave at some
point. Who is going to own these things
going forward? And that colors a lot of
how we do this setup because
oneoff niche campaigns that require like
an insane amount of technical knowledge
might not be possible.
And so I'm always asking when I'm
setting something up, who is going to
own this? How can I teach them to own it
properly? We do not want something just
randomly breaking after six months and
them them having to redo everything.
Setting goals and expectations. We kind
of already talked about this. Um what
are the KPIs for success? Generally,
really early on it looks like have we
met with all the stakeholders? Do we
understand what we want to do? Do we
have a good scope that everybody agrees
with? And then later on it's like how
many positive replies are we getting?
how many meetings are we getting? Um
what is working? What is not? At the end
of the day, the the threemonth GTM
infrastructure goal is just to find out
what is working and what is resonating.
And
that's going to pay dividends for you.
If you're a SAS company and you find out
this thing, these three things maybe
that you thought would really resonate
with the market don't, then we can move
on and do something else. and you're not
you're never going to spend money on on
doing it if you did it properly ever
again or you'll lean into what's
working. And so there is this is the
toughest part of any engagement is like
goals and expectations. Um sales really
wants their teams to have full
calendars. Leadership really wants to
make money and they're investing a lot
of money into this G team
infrastructure, right? So yeah, once
we've met with all the stakeholders, we
move into the audit phase. See what
they've done in the past. Audit the CRM.
How bad is it? How many contacts are in
there? What do you guys think your
target area market size is? We'll do a
little bit of back and forth with AI to
kind of understand your business a
little bit. We'll also look through your
sales calls. Like I will physically look
through them rather than just feeding
them to AI. And we'll come up with a
scope that everyone agrees with. We
decide to work together. Great. We've
done all that ground work. we on board
and we start to reserve the email
infrastructure which is super important
because I'm going to say this going
forward is that companies must wait 30
days to send that serves two purposes
one we decide what's really important in
terms of outcome and then number two we
don't get any uh like virgin domain
flags from
um like it just allows us to fully use
the infrastructure if if you're sending
from a new infrastructure ffstruure and
the domains are only like two weeks old,
you're going to get higher bounce rates.
You're not going to get to utilize the
infrastructure as well as possible. If
there is like an event or something
highly impactful, there might be an
opportunity to use generic
infrastructure, but I would discourage
it. So then we move on to market
research. This is the period in which if
it hasn't been done already, I am
understanding your business. My team is
understanding your business. You are
feeding us documentation that will help
us understand your business and not
because we don't trust you but we want
to verify. We will go through market
research with AI the best AI models that
are available. This changes from time to
time. We will decide how to segment your
verticals especially if you're a
horizontal SAS. This is really
important. Um we'll go through
ICP uh ICP um documentation. Basically,
who is your who is your ICP? These
documents are going to be the foundation
for the future. What is your target area
market? Like, who is the ideal person
you want to work with? What are the
ideal personas? Some companies have
already done this. I like to at least
add to it. I'm like, hold on. I I get
that you think you know what you know.
We're going to go through every single
one of your best customers, all your
customers, your best sales calls, all
your sales calls, your turn customers.
um anything that we can get our hands on
and put that through a context model to
understand what is going on there. While
we're doing this, okay, so this is in
tandem. We are setting up signals that
will pay off dividends for the future.
So website visitors is like
non-negotiable. It's really helpful for
um attribution. Um, if somebody comes
and visits the website for the campaign
because website visitor identification
is not perfect, you will probably
multiply that number by 2 to 5x to see
who how many people are visiting your
website from the campaign. And we're
also setting up things like outbound
sync that automatically sync with your
CRM
to know people who you sent to, are they
coming in through other channels? That
attribution is huge. Often we've seen
that campaigns that would have otherwise
be considered a failure by reply rate
were actually successful in driving
traffic to the website and getting
interest. As I always say, at bare
minimum, cold email sent to your target
area market. Um maybe less targeted is a
private ads network and you know great
like Erin Oas said this. Um everybody
at minimum can use it like that. Okay.
So what are some other important signals
we can So the signals that are top down
are when you already have a company
list. Signals that are bottom up are
when you're adding to your TAM because
of the signal. And so right what we're
doing here is we're doing bottom up.
We're adding to our TAM from these
signals. Website visitors,
ICP job changes and hires at a smaller
list. We'll go into what we do when we
map the whole TAM out. Um and then
specific really specific niche. um
signals like let's say companies that
are sponsoring clinical trials that are
not in institutions are your ICP we can
do that using clinical trials.gov
Okay, really important stuff. TAM
mapping. Who are your best customers?
What verticals do you want to target?
What do you want to prioritize? Let's
map this out as best we can. We're
aiming for like 80%. Okay? We're not
going to aim for 100% of your target
area market in these in these 12 months.
It's just not feasible. I think the
people who who spend time doing 100%
target market or ICP map, they're
wasting their time. We are going for the
8020 here. Okay. We're also pulling in
uh we're at this point um getting ready
to launch the close loss campaign by
analyzing um sales calls and and lost
customers.
Um we are doing we're taking the founder
especially founder sales we're looking
at the LinkedIn followers and likes and
things like that. We're doing preparing
a social campaign and then we're also
analyzing your competitors potentially
pulling your competitor followers for
better campaign at the same time. This
is all happening towards the end of
month one. We are looking at your
inbound. Do you have demo form
abandoners? Do you have optins that are
not um that are not being sent to? What
what are you doing to follow up? That
kind of thing. Great. Getting ready to
launch this. Going through our
checklists. Finally, we're putting we're
coming up with prompts in clay and other
tools that will do your deep
qualification. What is deep
qualification? This is like a holy grail
type prompt that will take any company
or any person. Put it through put the
metrics every single metrics that we
have through and qualify the company and
do some scoring. Okay, scoring is only
important if you're limited by your team
size I would say or by your channels.
And ideally, we set up enough LinkedIn
profiles and enough inboxes where we're
not really limited by how much we can
send. Okay? But that's not always the
case.
Then we're we're we're we're saying
hello to your town, okay? We're we're
not every single campaign that we launch
is going to be the most targeted
campaign of all time. They're all going
to be creative campaigns. There's going
to be a creative angle to them, but we
want to start, especially if you're a
new startup, letting people know you
exist. Okay? If we get positive replies,
great. We have interviews, we get
feedback, we push them to someone who
can handle that. If not, we're following
up or yeah, after two emails for these
bulk campaigns, we are stopping. We
don't want to. There's no reason. All
we're trying to do is say hello. So, two
emails,
add company level TAM to the CRM.
This is where we're starting to enrich
the CRM. Okay, we're putting all this
work and all these look alikes and all
this stuff we found from all these
sources into your TAM using a rubric
that we come up with together. Super
important. That is I would say that this
is like this is a little compressed.
It's like a twoe process minimum. Great.
We have your TAM in your CRM now. And in
Clay, we can use it. Now we go top down.
We have your TAM to find new hires. We
have your TAM to find job changes. We
can monitor for all the um like customer
support hiring signals that you were
looking for before.
So now we have a a nice loop going,
right? We're adding to the TAM. We're
monitoring the TAM.
Uh let me just get rid of this. And
yeah, then we're I mean for this
customer, this was a little different.
LinkedIn outreach happened later because
of the trust factor. They really really
I I really think that in terms of
outreach, like you you people are more
careful and and it hurts revenue than
they need to be. No one remembers a cold
DM that they got like three weeks ago.
Okay, for the most part, um, we are
doing things like prioritizing and
bucketing our lead list. We don't want
to send like say we have a huge company
that has tons of people that are good to
work with us. We don't want to send to
all of them at once. So, we are
bucketing and launching some of those
campaigns in LinkedIn and and then we're
also like se segmenting them out,
stepping them out for cold email.
Um, we're planning a reenrichment. How
often do we want to refresh the signals
that we set up? Like M&A funding um
probably every like 60 to 90 days if the
CRM is huge. Um we already kind of did
the step I already mentioned the step to
find essential data to find the data
sources that generally happens in like a
master sheet. Okay.
And then we're planning retargeting
possibly Stella growth won't be there
for that. Okay. But we're setting up all
this stuff so that the this
infrastructure can run without us.
Positive reply comes in from an automate
automated campaign.
Um double check that they're qualified,
which surprisingly is something that I
recommend doing. I recommend honestly
for larger SAS companies to do most of
the qualification on the back end, but I
can talk about that later. Um route
things properly. Save this in a clay
table.
um update it in HubSpot, enrich phone
numbers, push over to a Slack channel
for the VDRS. Okay, I think that's
basically all I have time for today. Um
I've got a lot of skitso uh
whiteboarding here, but uh this is just
one example of how you can do GTM
infrastructure. I hope you found it
useful.